hey it's Justine and the last time we
chatted about iPhone rumors we were
talking specifically about the iPhone 15
but now I want to kind of dive into the
iPhone 15 Pro I'm hyped about because
that's usually the device that I get so
we're in here on Mac Rumors I'll put a
link in the description if you want to
check out this full article but this is
every room or about the iPhone 15 Pro
and iPhone 15 Pro Max which are expected
in September 2023. let's get into it so
at a glance they're saying the 2023
iPhone 15 Pro Models are expected to
feature USBC now this is not just
specific to the pro this is also of
course on the 15 line there has been a
mandate that legally most phone
manufacturers are now going to have to
ship to USBC I'm definitely excited
about this so looking forward to the
future there's also rumors of solid
state volume and power buttons which
would mean it's not actually a physical
button anymore it's kind of like the
touch ID or the trackpad on the MacBooks
a new Periscope camera a17 chips and
more I like this little render very nice
very nice love to see it so far it looks
like iPhone 15 Pro Models will have an
updated design and it looks like they're
going to have it be a little bit thinner
with curved bezels and a new titanium
chassis and going off of the solid state
buttons it says it's going to be using
haptic feedback to mimic the Press of a
button which kind of makes it feel like
you're actually pressing a button you
also kind of get that haptic feedback
when you're using the keyboard so
something very similar to that will
carry over into the actual buttons looks
like we've got an a17 chip which will be
exclusive to the 15 pro and pro Max all
15 models will have the dynamic Island
so this is not just something special to
the pros this year it will be carrying
over on to the lower end models as well
we've got USBC Port that features a USB
3.2 or Thunderbolt 3 transfer speeds my
hair is blowing all over the place
because the air is on and I don't feel
like getting up to turn it off more RAM
expected alongside the a17 ship but all
iPhone 15 models will use the same 5G
Qualcomm modem for connectivity so for
the most part the iPhone 15 Pro and the
pro Max will have the same features with
one major difference that telephoto
camera this is not something new in the
Apple territory to add a better
telephoto camera on the higher end
models they did this before a couple
phones ago and it really does make a
difference but I did like this past year
how the iPhone 14 pro and the pro Max
were basically identical other than of
course the battery life and the screen
size you're kind of getting the same
exact phone so you don't have to pick
and choose and lose features one over
the other it says both models will
include the telephoto lens but the
iPhone 15 Pro will have a periscope lens
that will enable 6X optical zoom with
those notable performances over the 3x
zoom on the 14 pro and here we have a
photo a USBC just another leak to show
you that this is the direction that
apple is going into and of course our
lovely leaker really loves to let us
know who leaked it another image from
nine to five Mac they've had some really
great renders recently here we've got
some more renders and you can see the
camera bump is expected to be thicker
with thicker lenses to accommodate the
camera updates like it's so interesting
just to kind of see over the past couple
of years the evolution of the camera
bump on these iPhones because it's
pretty extensive here's some renders
from a cad drawing of the iPhone 15 Pro
Max showing it could be slightly thicker
than the iPhone 14 pro Max with small
reductions in the width and height so
the iPhone 15 is expected to be 0.4
millimeters thicker than the iPhone 14
pro didn't say that it was supposed to
be thinner I swear to you okay no bezels
with apple introducing thinner curved
bezels okay so not the actual phone
itself I'm like hold on a second
contradicting again these are all rumors
so nothing is really like actually set
in stone that's not true pretty sure a
lot of the stuff is actually set in
stone we just don't publicly know it yet
I mean Apple's already producing these
devices getting them ready for us in
September which is crazy to think about
so it looks like we have a 6.1 and 6.7
inch OLED display with cutouts for the
camera and face ID there have been
rumors of tweaks to the chassis of the
two Pro Models Laker shrimp Apple Pro is
talking about the thinner curved bezels
which I feel like they're even saying
here is similar to the Apple watch
because it does have like um the bezels
that kind of curve into the design of
the actual chassis itself which I kind
of think looks really good titanium is
lighter and stronger but it is also more
expensive because it is harder to work
with presuming no other major changes
and internal components that iPhone
constructed with a titanium frame will
be lighter than an iPhone with a
stainless steel frame so it's likely
that the 15 pro and pro Max will be
lighter than the iPhone 14. oh that's
interesting in addition to lighter
weight titanium has a different finish
than stainless steel so rather than it
being shiny it is more of a matte
texture so it won't attract fingerprints
in the same way oh my God please the
fingerprint magnet that is that
stainless steel band it's it's really
crazy I mean I have a case on it so I
really don't ever see it but as soon as
I take it out instantly fingerprint
Central now it's time for some colors
they're suggesting the iPhone 15 Pro
Models could come in a dark red color it
just upsets me sometimes that like apple
likes to make their Pro Models like a
darker kind of muted colors red is
definitely not in my favorite color list
but what is in my favorite color list is
pink so it's kind of like you know a
lighter red it's rumored that the iPhone
15 will come in this pink and these blue
colors like it's so so pretty absolutely
freaking love it why are you doing that
on the 15 and not on the 15 Pro like you
could do it just just do it even though
I'm not like a huge Red fan I think
it'll probably do pretty well more
rumors about the solid state buttons
saying that Apple already uses the same
technology for the touch ID button on
the iPhone SE and the trackpad on the
MacBook Pro and the MacBook Air models
on these devices you can use a press
gesture and it feels like you've pressed
a button but in reality it's a solid
surface with haptic feedback it really
is kind of crazy because the trackpad
press like at this point I've kind of
forgot that this isn't an actual button
so wild saying that Solid State
Technology can improve protection
against dust and water because it does
not need a physical depressing mechanic
but it does require extra Hardware
inside of the iPhone Apple is rumored to
be adding two additional tactic engines
to the iPhone 15 Pro Models to power the
solid state buttons in the current
iPhone models they have a single taptic
engine for haptic feedback so there it
is there's the little taptic engine it
was saying that there were some 20 21
rumors indicating that Apple would adopt
round volume buttons for the iPhone 14
and that didn't happen that could be
kind of cool like actually just like
round like little circular buttons I
mean I don't think there's really
anything wrong with these I feel like
it's pretty decent placement although
the amount of screenshots that I
accidentally take on a daily basis it's
a lot as we display it's saying it's
going to be equipped with a power
efficient OLED display driver chip so
that could lead to reduced power
consumption that ultimately could lead
to better improved battery life which we
definitely hope I know a lot of people
have been having trouble with their
iPhone 14 battery every life and it
hasn't been kind of living up to the
hype I have noticed though sometimes I
do get up at 5am and when I have those
early start days it does not make it
through the day but I am constantly
always on my phone so I'm usually never
too far from like a Mophie charger or a
wall plug or I charge a lot in my car
then of course we have a 15 Ultra which
I talked about in my iPhone 15 video
this could go both ways like there could
be an entirely separate phone that is a
15 Ultra or just an iPhone Ultra I don't
really think they would break it out and
do the 15 the 15 Pro and the pro Max and
then an ultra I do feel like the ultra
would kind of be something that they may
announce and then it's not coming until
like later kind of like they've done in
the past with some of the iPhones where
they've held off I don't know I just
feel like it could be something else on
its own kind of like the Apple watch
Ultra is separate from the Apple Watch
series apple is indeed working on a
higher end higher priced iPhone model
that can be worked with ultra but he
expects this iPhone to launch as a part
of 2024 in the iPhone 16 lineup that
makes sense all 15 models are expect to
feature usb-c port instead of lightning
the European Law requires all devices to
use a universal charging port so either
Apple needs to design an iPhone just for
Europe or make a worldwide change I mean
in typical Apple fashion like it kind of
wouldn't surprise me if they just made a
European version that was USBC but then
I feel like all of us over here would be
like wait a minute we want USBC too and
that would be trying to like import
European phones it could be a whole
thing so I feel like it's the smart
decision to just give in the iPhone 15
Pro Models are expected to support
higher speed data transfers which is
great especially if you're shooting
prores raw footage like that stuff eats
up space and it takes forever to
download and transfer Thunderbolt 3
transfer speeds so up to 20 gigs a
second at a minimum or up to 40 gigs if
Thunderbolt is sported standard 15
models will be limited to USB 2 transfer
speeds which is 480 megabytes a second
wire transfer of photos backups and
other information be quicker with faster
data speeds I don't know how many of you
really do a lot of that I definitely
import a lot of content to my computer
when I'm editing you could just airdrop
but sometimes I just feel like that also
takes a while and it's not always is
super reliable so sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't so it's just better
to plug it in import it all and we're
done ready to go one rumor from a
Chinese social networking site suggests
that Apple could place some limitations
on iPhone's USBC Port preventing them
from working with Apple unimproved
accessories they have done this with the
lightning Port but none of the USBC
ports and Apple's Macs or iPads have any
kind of restriction this room would
suggests that Apple could add an
integrated circuit interface into the
USBC chips encouraging customers to buy
genuine iPhone access encouraging
customers to buy genuine iPhone
accessories and protecting from
counterfeit and potentially dangerous
charging cables and adapters we love to
see it this is great because even when I
was working with Condor blue and we were
creating the lightning cables for my
pink eye to seeing cable we wanted to
make sure that those were mfi certified
which means they will work with apple is
genuine and we're using all of the
specifications from Apple to make sure
that it does work properly with your
phone because a lot of these cables that
you get like if you've ever used a weird
lightning cable and it pops up and says
this accessory is not supported that's
when you know it is not meeting the
specifications that Apple has set for
their phones which is good because we
want to have a higher quality cable you
don't want to be using something that
could be possibly damaging to your
device and my computer just switched
into
um to dark mode I have it switched to
dark mode as soon as the sun sets so
that must mean the sun has set so this
Periscope lens system uses a primary
lens to capture a photo with an angled
mirror or prism reflecting the light at
90 degrees towards a second lens that
then sends it to the image sensor the
image sensor and secondary lens are
positioned sideways inside the
smartphone to extend the focal length
and like they're saying here that that
takes up valuable surface area so that
is a kind of a cool little demo just to
show how that all works so Samsung has
been using Periscope lens technology for
a few years and their lenses can support
up to 10 optical and paired with digital
Zoom Samsung offers up to 100x digital
Zoom which is kind of incredible to
really witness it they call this the
space Zoom as for Ram the pro and pro
match are expected to feature 8 gigs of
RAM up from six gigs in the current 14
pro and pro Max Wi-Fi 6E and 5G I just
recently upgraded my Wi-Fi access points
to Wi-Fi six and it has been so
incredible it's been so much faster
there's been some speculation that Apple
could increase the price of the 15 Pro
Models because of the higher end
components
love a good price hike beyond the iPhone
15 Pro this is interesting there have
been rumors that Apple could Implement
an under display face ID technology as
soon as 2024 increasing the usable
display area getting rid of dynamic
Islands Samsung has done a really great
job of that under screen technology so
basically like the front camera on a lot
of their devices like you can't even see
it like it just completely disappears
and it just is so impressive to see in
person so I feel like when Apple has
that perfected then it's going to be out
and it'll kind of be more of a
widespread thing where most other phone
manufacturers will probably follow suit
so that looks like that's about all of
the rumors that we have here on Mac
Rumors I'm obviously very excited for
iPhone season we still have a few months
so don't get too unsettled yet we will
have some more rumors coming out soon
and of course I will be keeping an eye
on those as well if there's anything
else that you'd like to see me cover or
if you have any rumors or leaks that you
would like me to check out feel free to
leave them in the comments below or send
me a tweet because I'm always on Twitter
thanks again for watching if you haven't
already be sure to like comment and
subscribe to my YouTube channel I also
have a full video on the iPhone 15s if
you want to check that out I'll put a
link in the description and somewhere
over here on the end screen and with
that friends I'll see in the next video
bye
foreign
[Music]